des passionnés venus parfois de loin
pendant ces deux jours de rassemblement
le traditionnel festival de bd de bucca
fait de nombreux heureux parmi les fans
j'ai eu aussi une bd des schtroumpfs de
laurent cagniat qui est un vrai dire il
travaille pour les studio peyo donc ce
sont des élèves de peyo qui reprennent
le dessin et qui doit vraiment suis
vraiment les traits de peyo sinon j'ai
eu des auteurs espagnols et italiens
qui sont très difficiles à avoir dans
mon pays en belgique ce qu'ils ne
viennent pas souvent et même ici en
france ils viennent pas très souvent non
plus j'ai attendu pour avoir une très
belle dédicace du dessinateur qui
s'appelle alex macho et du coloriste
s'appelle gare luc aggir jeu là un
client fidèle du festival depuis de
nombreuses années et c'est très bien
organisé et quand on demande aux
amateurs la bd est souvent une passion
issus du plus jeune âge je pense que
c'est une passion déjà qui remonte à
l'enfance et
dans la bande dessinée il ya la fois le
le dessin bien entendu le scénario est
en fait le fait que la bande dessinée
soit un petit peu un art hybride entre
la littérature le théâtre le cinéma un
festival occasions même pour les fans de
découvrir de nouveaux auteurs moi je le
connaissais pas j'ai l'élu en forme
mesure et j'ai beaucoup aimé les
l'histoire finalement et ben voila je
n'ai acheté
et je les fait dédicacer une opportunité
unique d'échangé et repartir avec des
dédicaces qui ne passe pas inaperçu